how many cigars are you smoking now
what a show
no more than one no more than one more
than 100 sick is it is do you get any
nicotine from it oh yeah you do yeah for
sure everybody does interesting that's
why they smoke cigars they don't just
smoke it for the taste right that's
stupid that makes sense but you don't
inhale no but you do the the tobacco is
you know it's pure tobacco and you're
getting that in your mouth and you're
getting the nicotine in your mouth until
you get a buzz yeah 100 yeah 100 we were
even considering Ari and I were smoking
cigars once in the beginning of sober
October we're like are we cheating I
kind of feel like we're cheating I feel
like I'm getting kind of high
you get high from cigars 100 interesting
it's just a different kind of high it's
a it's a nice conversational high it's
right relaxed it's similar to cigarettes
where you don't get you're not [ __ ] up
but cigarettes do provide like a relief
or a release whatever that is whatever
that nicotine is why is nicotine so
addictive
it's not that addictive I mean um I like
it but I can like like if I uh was
smoking a vape pen a lot I was doing it
every day and then I just took it off
and just didn't do it for a week and I
just stopped craving it totally but
maybe that's just me you're you have a
constitution it's it's easier for you
you're very disciplined
other people struggle with that there's
other people that cannot
do that cigarettes are tough I've given
up ever I've given up cocaine alcohol
pills marijuana I've not done a drug in
12 years but cigarettes are time and I
haven't smoked now for two months but
did one day in the near future and I
don't know when someone's gonna give you
a cigarette they're not even going to
give it to me they just reach for it I'm
going to request it and you know spark
it out I'm gonna have a cigarette and
then I'm just going to be sitting
somewhere having a cigarette not knowing
how yeah not knowing how it happened
wouldn't it be awesome if they were good
for you it would be amazing
it would be a man well I love that scene
from sleeper Woody Allen movie where you
know he they freeze him and he wakes up
and they go uh he goes they go what he
goes what should I eat for breakfast
take a red meat eggs and cigarettes and
he goes what he goes no it's all good
for you he goes everything we thought
was bad for you it was like great for
you it's like chocolates have some
chocolate cake it was like it's such a
great scene well they're right about red
meat yes some of it's correct right
I think the sugar industry because
they're behind a lot of the fat activism
stuff are they really oh yeah so if you
look at it you know a lot of the uh
people that go listen there's no
different because you know they just had
this article the LA uh School District
was like don't tell kids that like junk
food's bad because it's classist and
racist or whatever
it's Insanity like don't tell them
there's any difference between foods and
what you know and it's all linked to
this like be always body positive no
matter what and a lot of that is backed
by like Nestle well I know there was
some body positive people that were on
social media that they found out were
getting backed by Nestle or one of those
companies yeah yeah and they they were
promoting the idea that there's no
difference in foods and there's no junk
food and it's all about your mental
health and yeah and you mentally healthy
apparently eating just ice cream on a
couch but it's all of it it's so
unscientific and the fact that that
doesn't get fact checked online is so
crazy right you can say you know
something about covid or something about
something else and you'll immediately
get that little Banner ether post
that'll tell people that what you're
saying well they always use some example
of like a person who's robust a little
chubby and go this person's healthy and
then they'll always Point like a skinny
heroin addict and go this person isn't
yeah and you go yeah but that's not
the overall yeah you know thing yeah
even if you're even if you're
like 50 60 pounds overweight and I fit
yeah you're still less healthy than you
of course if you weren't 50 60 pounds
overweight I think some of it is that
there was a weird period when I was
growing up where all the models were
like sickly thin yeah where they were
like gaunt they wanted them to be like
hangers they didn't really want them to
be half bodies well it was like the
Balenciaga thing right that came up with
the kids where it was like this is
creepy and they're weird and of course
you probably saw that like that weird
advertisement where it's like kids have
these BDSM Bears these bears that are
dressed up at like leather daddies and
kids have them and and people with
fashion have always been creepy and
weird because like when I was growing up
the 90s it was heroin Chic and they made
all these young girls look like they
were strung out junkies so it's like
they've always been kind of off well
don't they kind of promote amphetamines
to a lot of those gals I hope so no yes
uh
but you can't be against fat activism
and against amphetamine like right
somebody's you know
um no they do I'm sure they promote well
fashion is all about sexual currency
like everybody asked me about how you
know they talk about Hollywood what I
think I'm like Hollywood's run on like
sex appeal I'm like not the one I'm in
I'll tell you right are you in Hollywood
though yeah I have no idea I have a
house there but like the this idea that
like people talk about Hollywood like
it's just one thing and they're like
it's run on sexual currency I'm like
yeah not the lineup at The Improv you
know like not the lineup of The Comedy
Store that was Roseanne is right there's
a lot of people where it was yeah but
like yeah those fat because all of these
human trafficking people they love their
like hooks into fashion like really oh
yeah so John Luke Burnell who is the guy
that you know was like a big Epstein
Confidant and Associate was like a high
level fashion photographer and it makes
sense because like you're they're
recruiting these girls when they're
young and they're impressionable and
they're like you know hey here's this
guy and just laying back like here's so
if you want good looking people you're
probably not gonna to go to a comedy
club right you're going to go to a
modeling shoot yeah not that there are
good looking Comics but I mean like
young impressionable good-looking people
are found in modeling so I think that's
why a lot of them it is a bizarre job
it's a really strange and you like
what's the woman's name that was married
to Tom Brady Gisele Bundchen she's worth
more than him
well yeah how just by being hot just by
being hot isn't that amazing it's huge
greatest quarterback of all time in the
biggest game yeah in all of North
America right and a woman just by virtue
of being pretty right wins she wins she
wins well and she's like I'm done with
this guy he keeps wanting to play
football yeah but now you're looking at
it's changing it's changing we're pretty
now like if you're a model I mean they
things that the look is changing right I
mean it's there it's a lot of bigger
people and it's a lot of not as pretty
people or not traditionally pretty so
yeah it's not all changing but there's
some you can't deny nature you can't a
hundred percent nature is it's all about
well there was no fat activism on
Epstein's Island you know what I mean
like he was not maybe there was I mean
there's I mean I don't think he was like
concerned with diversity like the you
know the people that are purveyors of
just people's looks are just you know
maybe he had a request list he might
have who knows
right you know it's yeah like you fill
out a questionnaire yeah you know like
you fill out a questionnaire like the
spoke post the question is there's been
people like that that have been sex
trafficking forever yes but it's
shocking to people that it's going on
now they're like what still but here's
yeah it's it there is sex trafficking
for sure but there's also like I was I
was in Romania I did a Bitcoin Guy
brought me over there to do his um
birthday party didn't you hang out with
Andrew Taylor I did I did 20 minutes of
comedy and I it bombed because it was
people weren't really speaking English
and the ones that could didn't love me
so some of them liked me and one guy
pointed at me and just yelled Joe Rogan
because he had seen me on this some
Russian crazy guy just got it for the
middle of the set went Rhoda got Joe
Rogan and then sat down and they like
brought him out it's it was insane and
but they paid me a lot of money to do it
and then there was you know there's only
one person there to really interview and
it was Andrew taste I went to his house
and he's a lovely guy here's the thing
about him and his brother they are
lovely people whether they're human
traffickers or not they're lovely people
I'm not for human trafficking but they
took us out for a steak dinner and there
was women there and a lot of the women
were quiet and I thought they were just
quiet
that would be my story if I'm called to
test if I would go the women were quiet
and they were obedient and many of them
looked at the floor but really yeah yeah
it was but it's eastern Europe Joe
that's kind of the way they act and
coming from America was a little bit of
a nice change of pace we stunned
no I mean come in for this nice comment
yeah we stunned when he got arrested
it wasn't stunning it wasn't still like
when eventually I smoke another
cigarette would I be stunned that I have
a cigarette in my hand no I wasn't
stunned that he got arrested it was
surprising to me because listen people
say things about somebody and you hope
that they're not true right because he
has some wacky opinions but he has some
opinions that I would say are probably
you know pretty pretty reasonable and
interesting and interesting that people
should you know stop being victims and
go out and work and figure stuff out and
that you know they're they this world
does leave you out in many cases and you
have to figure a way around things right
he calls it the Matrix or whatever but
like you have to be pretty like
resilient
um I think some of those messages are
good I think some of his stuff is funny
and over the top but you clearly don't
want this to be true you'd never want uh
you know this to be true and I hope it's
not true
um they think it's true I mean
is Romania corrupt yes it's corrupt it's
a Soviet you know Eastern Bloc country
where I think a lot of people get paid
off I think Tate even talked about that
it was kind of a corrupt country and
that people just kind of paid each other
off and like I think it's just the way a
lot of those Eastern European countries
work where you know America's corruption
is is and you know Tate you know kind of
made this point right American
corruption is a big deal corruption
billionaires right you got to be you
have a lot of money to play the game you
got to have the you know serious capital
in places like that you know you don't
have to be a billionaire to influence
things you can have a small business and
have enough money to be like you're in
the game you pay you pay people off to
get the business open and then you pay
people off to keep the business safe and
I think it's kind of maybe the way
America worked in the 70s before
corporations owned everything hmm it's
what it seems like but again I only
spent why did he move to Romania he
isn't he from the UK yes well um that's
certainly not a great
part of his defense is that he's living
in Romania he did live there his
attitude was I live here because I like
the freedom to do what I want
um but some of his detractors would say
that it's easier to get away with stuff
there he's even kind of said that you
can kind of do what you want you can
kind of do what you want now maybe that
means driving your car fast also it
might mean you know human trafficking I
don't know that's all he runs the gamut
but you can get away it's it's a weird
place to live if you could choose to
live anywhere it's an interesting place
to live the people were lovely
um you know have you ever thought of
where you'd live outside of the United
States
I mean I probably have to go back with
my people in Ireland I think we all have
to go to our people I mean you'd go to
Italy we have to go to our people no
yeah
I think
I go to my people and they're just
laying around eating I know maybe I'll
go to your people they stopped they
stopped building Cathedrals and well my
people are drinking but I mean I guess
you I mean I don't know if I'd go to
Brazil or something I think you know
I've been an island I've performed in
Dublin and it's kind of like I don't
know you feel I don't know that I'd ever
live outside of the U.S but you do feel
like a little bit of a kinship do you
feel any of that when you go back to
Italy not too much okay no I enjoy it I
enjoy their way of life I enjoy the way
they behave I like Ireland they're all
tortured they're tortured you you gotta
see the new movie The Band she's even
sharing yeah it's really good it's the
crew from In Bruges it's amazing it's
like Colin Farrell Brenda Gleason Martin
McDonough direct it's really good and
they shoot in Galway Ireland Ireland's
beautiful it's beautiful it's not
raining yeah when it's not raining it's
beautiful yeah but yeah but the people
there you know it's it's a very
different lifestyle than America so I
don't know that I could ever do it but I
don't know where would you go
well the only reason why I'd go is
there's some horrible [ __ ] went down the
United States and what are the chances
of that it's just
I mean if [ __ ] if like Manhattan gets
hit with a nuke right that's not a good
sign no and that's when you have to
really think oh my god do I stay here
right if La gets hit with a nuke it's
like uh
they deserve it you know you go well you
know
as long as I'm not there I'd be like uh
I would be sad I would text Andy
Letterman like love you goodbye yeah but
yeah but Manhattan gets hit with the new
because New York's the nerve center of
the country so if that gets hit we're in
trouble isn't that weird that New York's
the nerve center not really if you've
been there well because it's number one
it was before America it was a Dutch fur
training Outpost it was a Marketplace
but in America is a capitalist country
so the the everything's about Commerce
and New York predates America right it
goes back to the 1600s those are really
oh yeah New York it was New Amsterdam
you know before oh that's wrong yeah
before America became anything
um and um it's just the best city we
have it's the best we can do as a
country now not everyone's going to want
to live in a place like New York it's
expensive you live on top of each other
but it's got the best of everything when
you when you think about you know all of
the things that a country can do New
York probably does them all the best for
what we can do as America food yeah I
mean everything like that education I
mean all the big companies a lot of them
are headquartered there it's kind of
Market yeah it's an amazing City you
have this amazing diverse population of
people that all become kind of New
Yorkers and all kind of meld together it
it's it's a real City you know what's
great about it before the crime really
really upticked crime's not helping the
the thing was great that you would be
around everybody would just like from
all walks of life would walk on the
streets together and ride the subway
together it's like there's a real
mixture of people whereas in Los Angeles
people are just in their cars Los
Angeles is an isolating and lonely place
where everybody's out for the same thing
which is Fame yeah and if they're not
out for they're out to capitalize if
they're not out for it even the doctor
in Los Angeles will brag about his
celebrity clients right like you're
going to Los Angeles in many cases to to
build something right you want and you
know it's it becomes it's not a
community in the way that New York is
New York feels more like a community and
you get the best of everything so you
have people in New York that are like
going to be the best Architects or the
best chefs or you know maybe the best
baseball players or the best whatever
you know and you you put them all
together and like there's Excellence all
around even the buildings when you look
at the buildings in New York you go you
know Emery Roth or you know all these
great Architects Henry hardenberg built
a Dakota where Landon lived or the plaza
like you're just around this amazing
architecture some of it's been around
for hundreds of years and it inspires
you and you feel great I was watching
this online piece about this lady who
pretended to be a billionaire so that
she could go to all the different places
that were being sold yeah and so she
could take photos of their views yeah
but it was a really interesting
perspective no one should have this kind
of money no one should have this
interesting well how do you stop that
you cap their money you can't stop it
and I was also like I've been doing that
too going to places I can't afford
looking at them but I don't take the
tactic no one should have that kind of
money you take the tact one day I I look
at it and go I'd like this kind of money
yes
um I think that there's a limit where
money doesn't make you happy but it is
nice to have and this idea that you know
there is a new generation of people
coming up where fulfillment is the main
thing which I understand and that's good
but I also think at the end of the day
like you know we shouldn't lie about the
fact that like
being you know working and like getting
the benefits of earning a living that
you can be comfortable with is good and
you're not always going to be happy all
the time yeah not yeah every job you
have you're not going to love right I
think a lot of young kids coming up
right now are like I need to be inspired
at every moment of the day or I need to
be really and it's like there's a lot of
[ __ ] jobs that you do and you don't
realize why you do them until you get to
the next thing and then you go oh I
learned something in that job that I
didn't realize I needed well money
doesn't make you happy but it does
relieve desperation and Desperation
makes you sad that's true that the
desperation the the desperation of not
knowing if you're going to be able to
pay your bills and that pressure and
stress of it I clearly remember when I
got my first development deal and I got
money in the bank and I just like it was
like a weight of like a physical weight
had lifted off my shoulders because For
the first time in my life I didn't worry
about how I was going to pay the rent
and that was interesting because I was
like that is what year was that 93 and
that was the first time you took a
breath yeah yeah I was like wow this is
what this feels like it's hard
especially with comedy because when you
start there's not a lot of money for a
while no you're barely getting by you
got no health insurance you know you're
getting a couple hundred bucks here a
couple hundred bucks there you're trying
to scratch together a living pay your
rent pay your bills pay your gas bill
yeah and when you get done you know with
the week and you pay all the stuff you
know you don't have anything left and
that's how you're living you live in
hand to mouth yeah and you're always
wondering like am I gonna fill my books
so I can get enough road work so I can
pay everything and you know you don't
know where it's going to go and then
getting a big check I got a big check
from Disney of all people and uh oh I
started going to restaurants eating nice
I was like this is my manager actually
thought I had a gambling problem yeah
because he saw what you were spending
yeah no I'm eating out right
it's
interesting when you when you transition
from from being
anxious about that stuff to at least
having a taking a breath and going
it's a huge Advantage yeah it's a big
Advantage you can focus more on being
creative but the hunger is good too yeah
the hunger of not knowing where you're
going and what's going to happen that
fuels people but it doesn't fuel
everybody some people don't have the
Constitution for it and [ __ ] them up
yeah so many of the Articles you read
now are about how they're they seem to
be preparing people to live with less
going you don't need to own anything
you'll be happy that's all World
economic Forum no I know I know it's
shitty that's true nonsense but it's
also because people don't have anything
that's right and when they don't have
anything and they see people who have
things they think there's something
wrong with those people there's no way
they did it the right way those people
are all criminals yeah like there's this
attitude that people have when they're
poor when they look at people that are
wealthy like those people are evil
there's no way they're not evil which is
ridiculous it's ridiculous because if
you got a job that paid more money and
you kept working up and you got more and
more money and you're the same [ __ ]
person now all of a sudden you're
wealthy are you evil now right did you
do do this by subjugating people did you
do this by stealing no well there's such
a vast Chasm of like intelligence too
right so you have like brilliant people
and then you have people that are you
know they're just kind of struggling and
I think that like sometimes even
understanding the world that we live in
and even understanding how to make money
right or is difficult for a lot of
people right there is also a lot of
[ __ ] and a lot of corruption like
sometimes bad people get a lot of money
but that's just the way it is there's
bad people without a lot of money you
know yeah but it's just understanding
how to make money is difficult I think
for a lot of people because you don't
learn anything about money in school you
know you go through 18 years of school
you don't hear the word credit card
interest rate I mean it's kind of
amazing you know you get some basic
economics courses in high school but
like the consumer economy like the
things you would need to learn you just
don't learn a ton about that all right
how much did I discuss with you about
how student loans you yeah have to pay
back no matter what yeah not really if
you go bankrupt yeah they're not really
like you know maybe they're doing it
more now but like if they leave out this
stunning amount of information that you
would need and I think a lot of people
you know are are you know you very smart
people that can tell you all about
history or whatever you know and I've
been one like a person who like I
remember one of the first credit cards I
got it had like a 200 activation fee and
the limit was like 250. this was years
ago I tried to use it at a restaurant
they're like this and I'm like this is
impossible it had to go through I just
got it and it literally I looked it was
a 200 activation fee and I only had 50
whatever dollars available credit like
you get in that system and you [ __ ]
yourself it's hard to get out of it I
know a lot of people did that when they
were struggling they got into credit
card debt and the interest rate keeps
going up and
then you get under you're only paying
the minimum amount every month so just
like the the actual chunk of money that
you owe doesn't really shrink what's
good about America is there's no debtors
prison so you can declare bankruptcy
that is less that is unless you have
student loans that's the one thing
that'll get you on but I'm always I tell
people all the time just declare
bankruptcy and just let it go
Let It Go yeah but if you let the
student loans go you can't let the
student loans go but I say don't even go
to school like it's what are you even
doing in college I mean when you think
about it what is every story coming out
of an American University is like some
insane it's like they've they're holding
the teacher at gunpoint now because she
said you know something nice about
Colombia like I don't even understand
what anyone's learned unless you're like
a finance guy I'm going to Princeton or
your Tech person you're going to
Stanford but these low-level mid-tier
schools do we need them I mean they're
just they exist for like football and
it's fun you have fun you go get [ __ ]
up for four years you enjoy yourself but
like do you really
I don't know what you get out of it and
it depends on what you're trying to do
if you just want an education you just
want to have more information and you're
not thinking about using it as a career
yeah which nobody does right but if you
did that you you could learn some things
in college and if you wanted to be a
doctor well that's the way to do it if
you want to be a lawyer that's the way
to do it you have to go through
University but we don't need more of
them like we don't need more doctors we
don't need more lawyers and in in terms
of doctors we probably don't need more
doc we have enough doctors
in terms of like you know you know we
have a lot of doctors we have every kind
of doctor we have plastic surgeons we
have all kinds of it's like it's you
know especially because yeah but they
die off
that's good point I guess I mean they're
not gonna keep refreshing population but
if you're not gonna be a doctor you're
not gonna be like a lawyer it's stem
yeah we've got a few people doing
engineering most people are just in
marketing people go I'm in business Mark
you've ever talk to kids they're like
I'm a business they have no idea what's
going on they don't know what to do
they're filled with hormones they're
partying outside their house for the
first time living in dorms yeah getting
late it's a good experience yes it's a
fun experience I never had it I went to
Community College and I dropped out to
start selling subprime mortgages so I
regret not going to college but I like
my journey was meaningful too but yeah I
regret it I regret not going kind of
what do you regret about it the
experience that you would have had in a
college where you're living on your own
with everyone your age
but I think I I you know my life would
have been very different had I done that
I don't know but it might have been
different probably so I think though the
life I had was was good because I I love
comedy I like what I do and I think it's
good to go through crazy [ __ ] and have
it be funny but I think
a college experience is interesting if
you make the most of it you ever think
about what life would be like if you
didn't do comedy
yeah I do like during the pandemic how
long did you go without doing comedy I
think I was doing the podcast every week
but I did uh you know when they shut it
down in March
and then I think the first time I was on
stage might have been
you know
I did a comedy club Vinnie brand in in
New Jersey opened up the stress Factory
outside and he had an entire outside
theater tent he had a tent and I don't
know when I did that but I did it and it
might have been three or four months
maybe it was five months I don't know I
don't know I can't remember exact might
have been longer than that but it was
weird yeah you thought about it you're
like what would I do well what was weird
to me was when it seemed like there was
a possibility that we could never go
back to doing it again right the first
few months I was like what if it just
stays like that what if it stays like no
shows ever again right and I just have
this distant memory of what it's like to
do stand up because it is the best thing
the internet's fun but it's like being
in a room with real people that are live
you need that human connection yeah it's
a great time because some of the
YouTubers that never are around people
like it's a little weird oh yeah like
the people whose entire interactions
with everyone in life is just on the
internet you can you can look at them
you go there's something off when you
talk to them like they're kind of like
they always hate that they're not online
like when you talk to some of them in
real life they're kind of like they want
to be in front of a computer screen
that's where they're most comfortable
yeah and there's something they're
accustomed to it's what they're
accustomed to and it's a little sick but
for me I I love that I grew up without
that and now we have it but I like that
I didn't grow up in front of that school
yeah well I personally it definitely
does something about your Social
Development and there was a an article
recently about how it affects children's
brains in a measurable way like this
connection to social media yeah it's
undeniable if you're if you're not
interacting with people for the most
part and you're most of the time like if
your job is to be a streamer right and
the more you stream the more money you
make and you're streaming all day your
connection with humans has got to be
very strange and different than anybody
that's ever existed before yeah it's
very interesting because you are
interacting with people yes but you're
not interacting with anybody in person
right A lot of it is just you putting
something out out there and then people
reacting to think you put out there it's
almost like sending a messenger pigeon
it's very interesting it's definitely a
unique
vantage point where because you look
also dealing with people online that a
lot of them are Anonymous a lot of them
are kind of you know it's different than
it would be if they were in front of you
yeah speaking to you face to face you
know people are you know really either
you're trolling or they have their guard
down they're saying whatever they want
to say some of them are being completely
honest some of them are just trying to
have fun some you know yeah so you you
get to see like you know maybe the best
and worst I don't know it's interesting
well you get to see what people are like
in the back of their mind without social
interaction without communicating with
people you get to see like this little
the little base thoughts that people
have right shitty ideas that people have
about other people and just right just
the shitty ideas they have about
themselves right it's astounding to me
how many people like when I go on social
media if I just randomly scroll through
Twitter how many people talk about their
mental health and how bad they're meant
yes it's it's well it's because I talk a
lot about it on stage now you know
having a mother who's mentally ill
genuinely right and I don't mean that
other people you know that obviously
mental illness is it's running rampant
but it does also seem like there's a
difference between the mental illness my
mother has where she's a schizophrenic
genuine skit you know she didn't
diagnose herself on Instagram she's
genuinely she's in an institution she
cannot live in a you know I think that's
different than like you know for example
you know depression and depression is a
very bad thing but there's clinical
depression there's also situational
depression right some of the things that
you're doing or eating or being whatever
you know how do you discern it's hard
what's the cause though it's very
difficult because when someone is
diagnosed with clinical depression but
then you look at their actual lifestyle
and you look at what they're doing and
what's fulfilling about their life
you're like well of course you're
depressed some people clean that up yeah
how much of it would affect like I don't
want to be dismissive of people with
yeah chemical Impressions because I know
people that have it yes and I know
people that have taken antidepressants
and have changed life and then they
weaned off of them and then they're
infinitely better off than they were
before they took them yeah because they
were on the verge of suicide some people
have a chemical imbalance and some
people that can be corrected with
medicine some people really the
depression comes from a situation in
their life they can clear up some people
have anxiety because you know again they
they have this disorder but then there's
a lot of people that have anxiety
because like
you know maybe they're in a job they
hate yeah maybe they're in a bad
relationship and then there's some
people that just genetically their brain
is [ __ ] that's right that's real
that's true yeah there's there's people
and that's schizophrenia right when you
use the bathroom you always close the
door behind you right you don't want
random Patches by looking in on you so
why would you let people look in on you
when you're going online make sense does
make sense using the intranet with
expressvpn is like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door vpns are huge
now it's very important it's very
important because I have expressvpn
everybody does because the the thing is
they sell your information those
[ __ ] it's called Data
harvesting and Mining and you want your
privacy and the best part is using
expressvpn is easy as closing your
bathroom door you just fire up the app
click one button and you're protected
it's the number one world VPN rated by
Mashable The Verge and countless others
vpns are huge now if you're online
without a VPN it's like a huge problem
and people die
so if you're like me and you believe
your online activity is your business
secure Yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com I want to look at your
history
yeah it's great it's my name it's just
me
over and over and over and over and over
and then Zillow and Zillow houses houses
um uh I just imagine where would I be
happy would I be happy there maybe
that'll make me happy
um go to expressvpn.com Tim Dylan today
use my exclusive link
expresvpn.com Tim Dillon uh and you can
get an extra three months free that's
expressvpn.com what about that guy that
just killed those you know I don't know
if he even killed them to Idaho guys
that's a [ __ ] crazy well it's weird
because for six weeks they were like we
don't have one lead and then everyone's
no no no no no no yeah they didn't talk
about it because you don't talk about it
when cops are investigating something
yeah I mean they do they vacuumed that
place looking for DNA they've got
genealogy DNA right so they mapped hit
the DNA to people that were related to
this guy crazy yeah so it's not that
they didn't have any leads they didn't
share it well why would they because
it's entertaining for me I would like to
know I would like to know that guy
scares the [ __ ] out of me no there's
people like that they say people like
that the people that went to school with
him said that he went back when he went
back to school now that this is
obviously if he did it that he was
noticeably happier and noticeably had
more energy and more lively and
interacting with people well which is
[ __ ] creepy that's a really sick
person yeah well this is a guy that was
studying criminal behavior and stuff I
mean he was that's crazy he came back
after and he was happier well that's
what they said but also this is hearsay
but this is also people that you know
know him and maybe they think he's a
creep and right you know who knows but
the idea that you could be have that in
your brain where you one day you could
just you could stalk these people or
whatever figure out how to murder people
and just go in kill these innocent
people and leave and go to school the
next day like that is somebody's brain
that's [ __ ] there's no other way to
say it there's no other way to say it
there's no other way to say it and they
think there's just a certain percentage
of those people like there's a certain
percentage Association and I guess the
challenge is identifying them yeah
Psychopaths that's where the tax or
stuff comes in and you start to get
nervous about it because like they'll be
like well we want to start identifying
those types of people early it's like
yeah but that's almost you know you run
the risk there of you know drawing lines
around a lot of people we're never going
to do that who are either goofy or funny
or silly or saying dumb [ __ ] online and
then you know you they're like death
metal yeah they like death metal
whatever they listen to my podcast or
whatever they don't want to hurt anybody
yeah they don't want to hurt people
um but at the end of the day it's like
that's where a lot of that Tech stuff
comes from they're like well we where we
gotta identify these like anti-social
people that's Minority Report yeah I
mean that's what it is that's pre-crime
pre-crime yeah that's scary [ __ ] it's
scary it's scary also because like
there's people that at times in their
life like there was a guy who was on
this podcast
um you know John Bernthal the uh actor
yes break yeah yeah what an interesting
dude interesting like way different than
you know when people think of actors
they think of people that are insincere
this guy's the opposite of that he's
super sincere yeah really intelligent
really articulate very deep and
interesting guy and a really nice guy
too really really liked him but he was
talking about this guy that he knew that
he interviewed that was
um he was going to blow up a mosque and
he went into this mod he had this hate
of Muslims after coming back from
overseas right from serving and um he
was going to blow up a mosque and he
went in there and he met this woman who
welcomed him into the mosque and he was
still totally intent on blowing her up
blowing everybody up she invited him
over her home for dinner he was still
intent on it so he gets to know her and
his family completely change his course
becomes a devout Muslim
wow and then talked about the whole
experience about what his plans were and
that he didn't do it and now he's just
like very well that's like there was a
prison guard in Guantanamo Bay that
converted to
Islam he was a prison guard that's what
how you know you're losing the war
America uh by the way that's not a great
sign but he converted to Islam because
you know he struck up a friendship with
a guy in the thing I think people are
looking for something and that gives
them purpose the intensity of belief is
always interesting to me and the people
and I get like you know Camille pagley
wrote an interesting article about Obama
and she goes he's such a brilliant guy
but one thing he doesn't seem to
understand is like the like religion he
doesn't understand the passion and
intensity of like belief systems because
he is so intelligent that he doesn't
seem to grasp that which motivates
people like you know that is she how
does she know that though well she just
made comments on like the way he would
talk about religion I think this was
like after he made that comment like
people cling to their guns and their
Bibles or whatever and she was like I
don't think he fully you know
understands you know being a Harvard
educated guy like he doesn't fully
understand and you know that the the
religion provides a great comfort to
many people and an organizing principle
for their life right I do think that it
can it can spill over into this you know
fervor that's unhealthy right and you
see that with you fundamentalist
religion everywhere where it's like
whether it's you're a Christian or
Muslim you know there is a certain you
know value to critical thinking and not
cult you know Behavior but yeah that's
interesting or a story like that where a
guy goes in to kill people and goes well
I want to be one of you and it's someone
who's looking for something something
yeah well obviously just the fact that
he wanted to go in there and blow the
mosque up he's obviously in a bad place
he's not in a good place and sometimes
when people get involved in a really
rigid ideology a religion with a bunch
of other people that are committed they
feel a sense of community and purpose
and it gives them discipline and focus
and you know and you know the Islamic
faith is particularly rigid in that
regard yes and particularly devout a lot
of those faiths are if you follow the
letter of the law like in the Western
World a lot of our faiths have been
tempered by the types of governments we
have right so where we don't we have a
separation uh of religion and and uh you
know government
um but in other parts of the world they
don't and um I think one of the problems
now and you're seeing this kind of
resurgence
of religion which I think could be good
it depends right on on the form it takes
but a lot of the the Western world is
kind people feel an emptiness now that
we've you know religion isn't big in
America but we haven't replaced it with
anything like people are still at the
end of the day trying to figure out why
are we here what are we doing here does
anything happen when we die how should
we behave towards each other and we
haven't given them anything they had
this you know my grandparents would
devout cat my grandmother was devout
Catholic my grandfather was a devout
Catholic she was still a Democrat voted
she you know she was still like you know
not someone who you know but she went to
church all the time in her life and the
way she believed
um you know the we they were both you
know when they I was around both of them
when they died
um
you couldn't find a more peaceful person
as they were dying because they believed
they believed like my grandfather when
he was diagnosed with cancer and they
said you don't have much left he said
like you know my kingdom is not of this
Earth he's like that's fine with me he
was really at peace uh my grandmother
too my grandmother said I've lived a
good life and you know well that's what
people want that's what people want they
want to be at peace yeah yeah it's very
hard to achieve peace in this world
especially if you're doing difficult
things yeah it's very hard it's very
hard to the the just the battles you
have in your own mind but failure and
you know and everything that you're
doing in life just people that you
interact with the the chaos and you know
struggles and strife and and then the
why what is it all for if you don't have
a what is it all for it can get really
[ __ ] weird yeah and that I think that
not knowing that chaos people can't deal
with it
and it's easier maybe for people
that can block all that out and just go
but I think a lot of people struggle
with that a lot of people use drugs to
block it out a lot of people use drugs a
lot of people like amphetamines right
because it just blocks it out
you just keep going and yeah your
purpose isn't going yeah you know yeah
it just kind of gets muted yeah it's
difficult it's difficult I think for a
lot of people to just make peace with
the idea that
the unknown yeah you know like we really
don't know like it you know I mean you
could follow a system you can
try to be you know and that's where I
get some of that DMT [ __ ] that you that
helps people seem to people seem to come
back from some psychedelic experiences
and feel better about everything yes
yeah I definitely do yeah yeah that
definitely changed the way I look at
things yeah it's just the fact that
that's real that you can actually have
that experience everybody not know about
this how does how is this not promoted
yeah and obviously not for everybody
especially not for people who already
have a slippery grasp on reality itself
that's a problem what's a big problem
with uh psychedelics and not not just
psychedelics but like milder
psychedelics like marijuana and people
with schizophrenia yeah that's what uh
Alex Berenson wrote about in his book uh
tell your children yeah it's a very
interesting book because a lot of people
that are pro-marijuana including myself
you know instinctively want to regret
reject this notion that it triggers
schizophrenia but it does I think it
might I think with some people I mean it
doesn't with me but I think some people
that have a tendency or an inclination
towards that and they have like a really
heroic dose of Edibles or something like
that I've seen people crack I I know
multiple people in my life that have
gotten really [ __ ] up from weed and
got crazy and it's hard to know until
you've done it right it's it's basically
it's too late yeah like you know people
you know they smoke pot they want to
smoke pot and eventually like you know
maybe something is some underlying you
know Tendencies schizophrenia like that
stuff just comes out they don't know and
a lot of them are smoking it all day
every day and so that's the reality the
real the way they interface with the
world is through cannabis like they're
they're too much it's probably but some
people are fine with it and then
everybody's on pills right I mean
there's the amount of people that are on
ssris or depression meds or anxiety I
mean it's it's a massive amount of
people a lot of people there's so much
money in it yeah just get vaccinated
stop with the pills just get a coveted
vaccine every four months you'll feel
better about whatever's wrong will you
yeah I mean my aunt's on our ninth
booster and she feels great
she calls it gapis and I just got busted
ah she's great her eyes are blood red
she's you know I wonder if people get
addicted to doing it oh there's by the
way like they want to do it more often
we're going to read nervous we need an
article about the person who's gotten
vaccinated 100 times what's the personal
life that got vaccinated the most times
right now definitely somebody who's
gotten vaccinated way more than they
should what's the number you think oh I
don't know like you know how like people
that are hooked on Oxys that go to a
different doctor especially before the I
had a friend who was he [ __ ] himself
up I forget what his injury was but he
got on oxy's in Texas and then he moved
to California and got on oxy's with a
different doctor right and was getting
both doctors to prescribe him and then
he went off the rails Doctor shopping
yeah they call it well it's the fact
that I guess the doctor in Texas didn't
know that the doctor in La was giving it
to him right so he's getting double dose
and then he was getting it on the street
and then the next thing you know like
he's [ __ ] gone
yeah it's pretty normal before that
happened yeah there's definitely there's
there's got to be people that are
abusing vaccines like what I would like
to know like what's the moat is there
see Google this
is
it's hard to find person who's been
vaccinated I mean this guy by the way
there's no way Pfizer likes that article
no right it's got probably like online
support group Dennis is not putting this
person in anything yeah no no this is
they're keeping this quiet but there's
probably like some online oh yeah things
where people are like discussing like
you know there's there's people that
they feel like they should chop a hand
off yes you know yeah they feel like
they're not supposed to have a left hand
well there's also weird stuff where
people pretend to be disabled yeah like
it's crazy yes they they want to be they
want to be disabled there's something
it's like trans disabled yeah I mean I
mean but the brain is such an amazing
thing right like Oliver Sacks was just
amazing uh I forget what he was I called
it he wrote a book called The Man Who
mistook his wife for a hat and it was
this crazy book about rare brain
conditions where like people just for
whatever reason their brains function in
a way that was still puzzling even to
doctors even doctors were like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah yeah now obviously
that stuff keeps you up at night so you
don't wanna you know because you you
start to hypochondria I don't know I had
a headache yesterday did it make sense I
mean yeah the brain is like a very
complicated biological computer in some
ways like uh you ever drop your phone
and just starts doing wacky [ __ ] yeah I
I had a phone once I dropped it in
Hawaii and it just started calling
people yeah I would just I would hang up
and it would just randomly call someone
else hang up randomly call someone else
like look at this [ __ ] and that's what
your brain will do some people's brains
yeah it's just the wires are wrong
everything's [ __ ] something got
knocked loose and yeah
and that's crazy that's you forever yeah
that's what it's scary about Knockouts
like some people that have been knocked
out like they don't come back the same
person yeah they're in a new world now
yeah they're a new human with a new way
of interfacing because their brain is
[ __ ] yeah
are you now with all the bad press with
the nfts are you happy you never took my
advice yes
[Laughter]
not take your advice I refused
advertisements yeah that was smart yeah
there was a few of those crypto yeah
[ __ ] NF I'm like uh uh that's not
real yeah I'm not getting involved in
telling people to put their money into
something that I don't [ __ ] it's
tough it was a gamble you know and um
you know a lot of people lost and that's
you know now a lot of people getting
held to the account right there's a lot
of people Logan Paul a lot of these guys
people are people are upset at people
Tom Brady a lot of those people are
getting they're getting sued in a class
action lawsuit a lot of people are angry
yeah Paul you know like how about those
Matt Damon commercials where he's
comparing it to like Magellan and
[ __ ] people that's Transit on the
moon yeah yeah
be brave yeah be brave with your [ __ ]
entire life saving Kim Kardashian got
involved you know well those people were
throwing money around yeah they were
throwing a lot of [ __ ] money around
yeah not to me but we had uh we do
crypto ads on the show not for specific
things yeah we did crypto ads for like
like you know if you want to invest in
crypto here's a good service to invest
with but it wasn't like I wasn't like
pumping my own Dylan coin right you know
what I mean like I was doing that but
like yeah I mean like I I would still do
ads for FTX like if they I would still
do them if if they you know what I mean
if there was a plan like if Sam Beckman
freed said to me we're gonna make
everyone whole which is what he keeps
saying how is that even possible well
it's hard there aren't there millions of
creditors so much millions millions so
there's millions of people he owes money
to us even if he owes them one dollar
yeah he goes I just want to make them
whole like they keep interviewing him
and he keeps going my goal here is to
make the customers whole and so if he
called me and goes we're going to make
everyone whole and you know we're going
to pay your rate and we're going to get
in there and do some ads it's like I'm
not going to hold one mistake against
him do you think he thinks that he can
just do it again yes this is because he
did it already I believe that a guy like
that believes I was I was on I was in a
room with Bill Clinton I was in a room
with Joe Biden I was in a room with the
most powerful people in the world I was
the second biggest donor to Joe Biden's
presidential campaign I I can get out of
this and maybe serve my sentence or he
pled not guilty so he might be thinking
like there's a comeback story it's
what's getting him up every day there's
no way that a Redemption Arc is not
motivating his behavior do you think
they let him be on the amphetamines now
oh I don't know because wasn't that part
of the problem they were all jacked up
on pills well part of the problem was
they were just well maybe that's true
and I think that's part of the problem
part of the problem is this is also all
[ __ ] kinda you know that's also part
of the problem right that's the problem
Bitcoin like a lot of this stuff didn't
get implemented right it's not being
used it's not like the currency it's not
but you know FTX didn't even sh they
didn't even trade in Bitcoin no they
would do these other [ __ ] [ __ ]
which is really wild it's wild and then
they had to allow me to read you know
they were just doing a sex cult in the
Bahamas with ugly people and I'm for
that I'm for it too it's a great story
if it was real like if they were just
making money and banging each other and
taking pills called for gross nerds it
worked out great for a while yeah during
that time it was a wonderful story it's
amazing they couldn't get hot people
with the amount of money they had but
they just had gross smart people [ __ ]
each other on an island yeah how great
everyone looked gross nobody looked like
they showered people's hair was weird it
was a good old hippie commune yeah what
was the purpose of the Bahamas this is
the regulatory thing yeah they don't
want to be under the watchful life they
wanted to get out and do you know Jamie
do you know you're you're um what is the
it's Regulators us Regulators let's do
it that's all there's a bunch of cryptos
are down there no they're all down there
by the way they all moved to Puerto Rico
why do you think that is well it's all
taxes it's four percent tax rate and
they could kind of do whatever they want
and now they're all being found dead
what all these crypto guys a lot of them
are like one guy ended up he tweeted
like the cia's gonna kill me and then he
ended up in the ocean yeah well that was
it you see that that seemed odd a little
sketchy a little sketchy and then you
just ended up because a lot of what
happens I think with these guys these
Bitcoin guys is
the government has to understand the
stuff better right so the government has
to go and figure out how are you guys
doing whatever you know what I mean and
the government probably sends agents out
to befriend these people right and then
these people either figure something out
they shouldn't figure out or are no
longer useful and then what happens when
you're no longer useful is you're you go
it's not useful you're a liability we've
become a lot no longer useful so they
could possibly tell a story that's to
get people [ __ ] yeah that could expose
the identities of people yeah for the
guy who drowned what was he saying what
was you know that story Jamie right it's
but it is one of many and you know you
also have to think look look you're not
dealing with the the mentally the
healthiest people in the world not
really that's true CIA Mossad and pedo
Elite are running some kind of sex
trafficking entrapment black rail ring
out of Puerto Rico in the Caribbean
islands they're going to frame me with a
laptop planted by my ex-girlfriend who
was a spy they will torture me to death
by the way this guy's a fun guy to do
lunch with
you just want to talk I mean by the way
if someone if somebody said that to me
I'd go go on that's the gentleman right
there yeah oh boy oh boy I don't have
that look Sam bankman free you know what
I mean don't be Jewish but that is what
you would do if you were uh an
intelligence agency yes and you wanted
to entrap a nerd you would bring a hot
spy of course and they have hot spots of
course I've seen James Bond yeah that's
ripping in a hot spot that's what they
do that's how you know FTX was
uncompromised there were no hot spies
that's true that was uncompromised the
CIA was like I can't believe it they
actually want to [ __ ] each other
they have 10 people to choose from
they're all on an island guys and girls
just banging each other yeah and when
you're on that amount of amphetamines
and what else they're on who knows
they're probably enjoying every [ __ ]
second yeah the Indian guy's attractive
in FTX I will say that everyone else is
gross uh I don't want to I don't want to
put him in with the rest who uh the
India was an Indian guy who's attractive
but everybody else was kind of it was
rough he's probably the king he yeah it
was rough everybody else was rough well
freed was the king because he was the
brains The Mastermind Mastermind well he
also had that Mom that was a democratic
operative and they went to Stanford man
it's so funny because I walked around
Stanford I was doing the San Jose Improv
and I walked around Stanford and you do
get a Vibe it's interesting it's like
they are the Future Leaders those are
the tech you know it's like Harvard Yale
[ __ ] all that that old wasp money [ __ ]
that it's all about Stanford so these
are all the folks yeah he's the guy
that's the guy with the glasses to the
right of him is not bad looking you know
what take off those glasses that's the
best picture he took and if you saw him
in real life you'd go oh
no I think the Indian guy holds up no no
no that guy with the blue v-neck he
could go to the gym get jacked shave his
head he's got I can tell the features
bad skin I'll just tell him no I'm
telling you if you're doing good in real
life he had a horrible skin really be
very oily I didn't know I just feel it
oh you just I'm just feeling it you're
being mean I'm not being mean first of
all they stole everyone's money well did
we not make is he in trouble as well
because it seems like only Sam bankman
freed is in jail
other people flipped they became rats
what Caroline did right Caroline flip
because there's no honor anymore well
put those photos up there's one other
gentleman flipped who's uh which one is
he I believe he's Asian
if he's not he's culturally appropriate
if he's not he's got to explain it to
them yeah which which guy flipped I
don't know that I'm gonna guess that's
Gary Wang well or the guy next to him
got into my head that's scary what about
the guy next to him
that's a prasoud that's a wang okay and
so those I mean that guy to the left cry
I mean he looks like British are they
all oh there's Gary Wayne you know I got
it you son of a [ __ ] see Brett Harrison
already looks worse is that the same guy
dude he already looks worse wait that's
the same thing go back to the other
picture if that's the same guy that
can't be the same guy I'm telling you
Joe no that's not the same guy I
guarantee it's the same no it's the god
of the right of him isn't it we gotta
find it go back again let me see that
again and go back to the other one again
no yeah no no [ __ ] way I don't know
dude that guy's balding the other guy a
full head of hair go back full head hair
luscious yeah his hair is good no
there's no way that's the same guy
that's like a handsome fellow with the
v-neck I'm in I'm in his Corner okay
okay but let's let's see those are the
names okay so here's the Inner Circle
uh okay keep going that we know her
she's wild she's watching she's
listening to her talking there's I mean
yeah he's not no there's Gary Wayne he's
in trouble there's William mccaskill
okay wait a minute William mccaskill
Mentor he's a mentor Sam Bank from free
scroll back down again what does it say
philosophy professor at Oxford Chief
Architect of effective altruism didn't
we have him on the podcast did you have
him on the podcast are you involved in
this hold on a second
the feds break in right I think we we
had someone on the podcast
oh wow that's him that was talking about
effective altruism yeah he was a very
nice guy
and I think there was a request to have
him back on recently before the [ __ ] hit
the fan yeah that's him yeah handsome
fellow yeah he isn't bad no he's a very
nice guy well he was talking about
effectively sweetheart let's hear him
talk hear him talk a little bit
faster for learning they're going to be
interested in running because they're
now going to have huge amazing computer
power they're going to be able to create
simulations of the past
that um they're going to have some
interest in learning simulations of the
past
well the number of if that is true then
the number of Scottish uh
these future people are going to be
running will vastly outnumber the number
of actual
um timelines the kind of Base universes
it were
so for the one real Universe where
history kind of unfolds there's also
let's call it you know 10 000
simulations of that universe
and if that's true
then
it's the case that well given that I'm
just you know these things really are
indiscernible for the people who are
inside them it's overwhelmingly likely
just in the base plate that I'm going to
be in a simulation rather than
um in the real world
and what Nick Bossman says actually is
not that we definitely are in a
simulation but he just points out the
conflict between these three kind of
beliefs that we would seem to hold one
is that we're not going to go extinct in
the near future
two is that you know people in the
future will have some interest in
simulating the past
and thirdly that we're not living in a
simulation
and he himself gives you know a
reasonable degree of belief
maybe he thinks it's like 10 likely 15
likely that within a simulation
other people who understand the argument
vary a bit more but I think you know
it's something you should at least be
taking seriously
um the reason I've object it is kind of
um
uh even weirder I think
um or it's somewhat technical
um but the well what's interesting is
like see I'm sure I'm gonna give a dumb
answer so let's get out of there right
now sambang and Fred heard that and went
great we're gonna do it and we don't
care if the experiences are real well I
would imagine that Will mccaskill was
involved with them because they were
donating a lot of money to altruistic
causes and that's probably what his
position his whole thing is about giving
he gave away most of his income I
believe he only kept some very small
amount like thirty thousand dollars a
year and most of his money that he
earned he was giving away that's how you
know they're real bad folks when they
start giving away that's how you know
nobody's giving away his own money I
know but he lived a very simple life I
know so is Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
the Angels
um they're all giving all these
billionaires are like we're gonna give
away our money and we're gonna and we're
setting up all these foundations and a
lot of it's a fraud audits like a tax
scam and the other thing is like it's
never enough they're not just giving you
the money they're giving you the money
and then going and here's what I want
Society to look like that's the problem
they go here's my ideas on public health
policy it's like you started Microsoft
what the [ __ ] do you know about good
shut up this is what I want here's what
I want it is bizarre when they get
involved with public health why does
Bill Gates
yeah why is Bill Gates buying everybody
not to eat meat yeah there's a weird
thing where they have they want to
socially engineer society and they think
from where they sit they can do that and
the cover for that is we're doing
everything for you you're gonna love it
it's gonna be better and just to prove
I'm not a crazy lunatic who wants
control over you I'm look all this money
I have I'm giving it away yay here it is
I'm throwing it out and the reality is
they're just doing it to increase your
power base I mean it seems none of them
are broke
they're all just you know
interesting yeah the Farmland stuff is
wild it's wild why would he buy some
seeds you know he's he controls most of
the seeds he want they want margin they
want a meatless future but here's the
thing about because everyone can be
trans but then I go what's the point of
that like they just want to genderless
like everyone's genderless and like
typing a pod but Bill Gates I'm not
genderless that was the thing about
Gates is that he likes [ __ ] yeah well I
know and he's you know so to me I go
what is the pert like if everyone's like
this weird like you know androgynous pod
person I go who even benefits from this
I don't know
do you really think that's what they
want yeah if Society gets boiled down to
this thing where we're not dangerous
anymore they want a very docile oh uh
you know group of people and I think
this is what they've always wanted well
if you can make all the men feminine you
can make all the men feminine stop
Revolt if you can plug everybody into
the idea that they are always doing the
right thing and everything they're being
told to do is for the betterment of
others and there's this social
responsibility they have it's good to do
this and it's bad to do that right and
when you introduce all these things
because most people want to be good
people yeah so if you can get them there
which is why the woke [ __ ] goes so far
because people go I just want to be a
good person right right right right so I
don't want to deal with it you know so I
think that's a part of it they just want
everybody to be it's kind of a slave
state where everyone will just go and
work at their jobs and not complain yeah
and corporations will you know own
everything and everybody and you know
they tell you what they want I mean the
articles are out you know you'll own
nothing and be happy you'll you'll have
no savings you don't need to own a car
you don't need to own a house you can
just be on Uber well you will know where
you're going and isn't that wild that
you will own nothing and you'll be
happier this but this is the the and the
people it's Wilder that the people who
are writing that own everything
but obviously someone has to own things
right otherwise you would just take
whatever you want that article came out
I think it like Bloomberg or something
it came out and it came out in something
where you'd go what like this is the
people that own everything are telling
you that you don't need to own anything
and that the gig economy is great you
can just go from gig to Gig to Gig and
you're on you know you're on the grid
and well maybe the idea is like if you
wanted to look at it in the most
charitable way if you extrapolated to
the Future like what it may be one of
the things that's holding people back is
this desire to possess things and is
this desire to constantly accumulate
wealth and money and power and if it was
even across the board and we could just
concentrate on the things that we enjoy
doing and not concentrate on things
people don't enjoy it's not human yeah
that's the problem it's not it's not
you're talking about like things in
Idaho concentrated on what he enjoyed
doing and now we have four people dead
Everybody by the way everybody was like
oh kovitz here like no one's working
anymore it's gonna be a paradise look
everyone's Gonna Start Community Gardens
what happened I remember a lot of things
getting burned down
people need [ __ ] to do isolation too
yeah they shouldn't be slaves to their
jobs but people need things to do and
when you talk about people owning things
and material things like yeah people
want houses it's not only a material
thing right it's a it's a it's a it's a
way to basically provide a sense of
security safety Comfort yeah that you're
not depending necessarily on someone
else to provide you you're able to
independently give your family a certain
quality of life because you own a home
right uh when you own a car you have the
ability to travel and get a job that you
want per se you know you have more
freedom I look at all those things as
Freedom right like and you're right
there is a materialist angle of that
where like you can always get caught up
you know the house isn't big enough or
the car is not nicer or whatever yeah
but at the Bare Bones these people are
just I think trying to you know
basically self-actualize and have things
and the people that are telling them
they don't need any of those things I
mean well then what the hell are they
placing it with you know an apartment
you rent
and everybody will tell you the color of
the wall and you know the noise after 10
has to be that's why people stop with
Airbnb people don't Airbnb is going to
go out of business soon because people
have don't Google that but are you
saying that are you saying that just
because you got banned from Airbnb it's
completely a coincidence I'm saying this
Airbnb got too crazy with the rules they
kept telling everyone to clean their own
stuff up and people like well I'm paying
a huge cleaning fee and why am I not
supposed to be loud after 10 pm they got
rule obsessed and people are sick of it
and now Airbnb is going to go out of
business and hotels are back Everyone
likes hotels now Airbnb zero and hotels
are winning is this true yes people are
going back to hotels people getting sick
of Airbnb but is Airbnb like is that an
actual fact they're putting all kinds of
no I'm glad this is your podcast not
mine it's it's nobody and here's the
Brilliance of this setup no one knows
it's mine that's true I get all these
views because they think it's yours
right they think it's back on YouTube
it's great don't even say it's mine we
just put it out I start doing ads for
Traeger grill
um
but no I think I think airbnbs are they
got restrictive and there are articles
about it like obviously I'm kidding
they're not going out of business but
people started saying like hey man I'm
on vacation like when I check into an
Airbnb and there's 35 rules I don't feel
like I'm on vacation now is this just up
to the person who owns the home
yes but it just got too much but can you
look at that in advance before you
decide to rent a house I believe you can
so then
on you but it's a lot of them now a lot
of these things are like
you know everybody's just like there's
no don't because they're in residential
areas so they're like well don't be loud
after 10 and well it's got to be a
problem and because I know it's a
problem because I know a guy who owns a
home and right next to his home he lives
in a wealthy area and they rented it out
to tick tock kids yeah it's like an
Airbnb at a really baller putting on
some coffee yes there's a they rented it
out a little thank you tell me when
that's fine okay they rented it out to a
bunch of tick tock kids and they were
having all these parties all the time
and he started getting really pissed off
because like his neighborhood be crowded
with cars now and you know and they're
in this very wealthy community this
really nice house that's right tick tock
kids have a [ __ ] ton of money when I
would rent these airbnbs what happens is
I would just sit in the backyard with a
microphone and scream because I'd be
doing my podcast and people wouldn't
like it because somebody would be
raising their kids and I'm like Megan
markle's a [ __ ] and they're like what
is and I'm like it's my job it's
legitimately my job yeah to do I'd be
smoking cigarettes and yelling into a
microphone and they'd go hey man this is
not so I get it but you know that's why
people you know
I think are gravitating back to you know
Airbnb felt very pandemicy everyone's
like on vacation in someone else's life
let me see you know you know it's
interesting it was like oh you know
everything you know had become possible
during the pandemic and people were like
maybe you know people are moving around
people were questioning all kinds of
things and it was interesting like what
would it be like to live in wherever and
I'll live and how but now people I think
are just going hey man let's go to a
[ __ ] hotel The Maids come and they
clean they have room service hmm so I
mean that's what I think
sorry Airbnb
I think this might be motivated by your
hate for Airbnb because well it is off
the platform it is Airbnb is on the outs
or is it airbnb's once allotted a
vacation rental model begins to go stale
who disrupts the disrupter oh
interesting
has the Airbnb Bubble Burst according to
one recent viral tweet Airbnb hosts have
seen bookings evaporate since the busy
summer travel season
air bust Air B and bust is upon us
what's going on with Airbnb no bookings
at all okay so people who this is Airbnb
super hosts and also they're putting
more restrictions on rentals in certain
communities right so Tahoe look at this
it says has anyone seen a huge decrease
in bookings over the last three to four
months we went from at least 50
occupancy to literally zero percent the
last two months I'm just curious if
something's going on with my property or
if other people are seeing similar
things I'm in Palm Springs where you
located stop telling people now were you
had a problem yeah Josh Patrice stop
telling people to take their own garbage
out stop telling them to clean their own
dishes make it an actual vacation
experience for them get off your lazy
asses walk into your house and do the
dishes for people and take out the
garbage and have a maid do it they pay a
500 cleaning fee that should be cleaning
someone needs to clean so that's a huge
problem and that's the problem that I
had where it's like I'm paying a
cleaning fee I should also not have to
clean on top of that and stop with the
covid clean meaning it's fake well it's
a deep covered clean it's fake what do
you mean deep covered they used to say
that during the pandemic they'd be like
it's a d we're doing a deep covered
clean it's like number one it doesn't
live on surfaces number two this is fake
so they were charging you more money of
course
I just think that it's one of those
things where you know it's it's been
interesting to see it change right I
think and they're also putting Tahoe
just banned short-term rentals gotta be
30 days really interesting interesting
so they essentially put Airbnb out of
business there they don't want you doing
short-term rentals in Tahoe Jamie make
sure that's true but I believe that that
is true someone told me that interesting
well Tahoe is a big money place it's a
huge place and there's a lot of money
there but they're I think they're
getting sick of the short-term rentals
interesting the Tahoe kind of makes
sense to me have you ever swam in it
it's supposedly so cold it's like you're
you can't breathe like a ice bath kind
of interesting they say it's one of the
coldest Lakes it stays cold all year oh
it's a glacier Lake yeah Mark Twain said
it would revive a mummy yeah I've never
swam in it but supposedly it's really
like I wonder what the temperature is oh
I see above last year they capped
short-term rentals but this is a almost
a year ago so I don't know if something
happened since I'm trying to find and I
think when you said capped what does it
mean
um this is six month moratorium so like
whatever was there now you can't have
any more additional short-term rentals
added to this the county or the yeah
they were they were getting real upset
with short-term rentals and I think they
might have just actually just banned it
and just said you got to do 30 days see
if that's true I don't know if that's
true or not I didn't have an update yeah
my realtor said that I don't know if
that's true or not but oh why would you
reel to a lot of you I don't think that
a realtor I think he wouldn't yeah
so blame him yeah but it's uh you know
that the whole getting people to stay in
your house for a little while and
pretend it's a hotel but then make them
clean up that does seem a little
problematic it's weird it feels like you
should hire me it's strange and it it it
it's confusing because you check in and
you go well I want to treat this like my
house and I treat my house like [ __ ]
so here it is what does it say here uh
wired cities sites New York City and
Lake Tahoe as examples Arizona
sb1350 a law that passed that bypasses
states ban on short-term rentals means
that such a Crackdown is unlikely to
happen so what does that even mean oh
Airbnb effect while some locations
across the world have instituted
crackdowns or wholesale bands on Airbnb
such as New York City and Lake Tahoe
wired cities
where the article is I think I get it so
some locations have instituted
crackdowns or even wholesale bans so
that does seem to prove your point so
wired sites New York so it's Wired
Magazine that's got this going on gotcha
is New York City and Lake Tahoe as
examples
this article is about Sedona getting uh
crippled by the Airbnb gold rushes came
out five days ago it's also a creepy man
most people most airbnbs you stand
people are watching you what most
airbnbs you stand people are watching
you they're watching yeah little cameras
no not even like that but sometimes
there are weird cameras but like I've
heard it's just their surveillance it's
weird like literally they'll tell you
when you check in they're like I don't
have any people here because you're on
camera and the neighbors are watching so
it's like they're like don't have
anybody he over don't have any parties
like we're watching like when someone's
pretending to be a hotel but they're a
private individual that wants absolute
control but they don't understand how
hotels work this is why Airbnb is a sick
company that has allowed a lot of
people's like weird voyeuristic impulses
to take over and they've monetized it it
should be outlawed frankly they should
Outlaw Airbnb woman books Airbnb only to
find it's an abandoned Villa with
smashed Windows oh wow
so it's in Bali though right so this is
what did she get here no one home well
that's no one's supposed to be home
there's a pond smashed Windows where's
the smash Windows oh okay that's it well
here's the deal it's like
you know I it's it's interesting I think
if you have a large group of people I
totally understand like why you would
consider being in a plane but just go to
a hotel that's what you do now yeah I
mean you were a Mr Airbnb I use them all
the time because they were cool and they
were fun you could you could be like hi
I'm I'm living like a person who lives
in Suburban Houston right and then
you're like uh now it's just I've gotten
to the point where it's like well they
they got rid of me
and there was no process you know which
was unfortunate like there was no I was
not able to defend myself like there was
no like you know it's like it's uh the
way the platforming works they just go
you're done yeah so that was it
so that's unfortunate but so you're like
a little bit happy that they're on your
slide I mean I'm a little bit happy that
they're on the slide but I knew it
because I knew when you started asking
me to clean up after myself I know it's
over
it's in America and people need to be
able to like leave it like it's if if
the cleaning fee wasn't there I totally
understand right but the cleaning fee is
there it's like take out the garbage do
this do that like you live it's like
what
like kit what are you talking about this
is if I'm on vacation here in Suburban
Maryland in your [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] vacation so treat it
like such the problem with airbnbs is a
lot of them are like you know a lot
there's a lot of people that are trying
to make some extra bucks and they they
open a room or a garage or whatever it
is and it is good for certain people
right certain people are like hey
you know it works for me I'm new to this
area I want to see what it's like yeah
but for most people I think there's a
migration back to more traditional
methods
you know two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. I'm one of those more
than 50 million men in the U.S suffer
from male pattern baldness keeps this is
for people that are not successful like
you are
um who who need the hair some people
need the hair right some people just
have a bad shaped head that's true too
some people have flat heads because
their parents didn't pay attention to
them when they were little really
flat head flattens out oh interesting
I'm making that up oh I believe I think
it's just the way your head's shaped I
my friend because this is the way to
keep your hair in your head like my
friend started this it takes like five
or six months to get going but instead
of like some hair weird surgery he keeps
the hair that he has in his head yes so
that's the goal it's dihydrotestosterone
suppression exactly right it's a
derivative of testosterone is that true
yeah DHT is what causes your hair that's
one of the one of the lenses cause your
hair to fall out and and keeps gives you
this to the people well that I think
that's nice that they give that to you
and you know who likes this who experts
experts in the boldness field ah they
are huge into this
experts are recommending it
they don't tell you no they're experts
expert recommended history full head of
hair be it's experts you got some gray
coming in I do but I diet sometimes what
color you should go Blue you could throw
everybody off I'm telling I said many
times if I dyed my hair blue and moved
to Portland I have five blocks of the
city under my control by tonight I just
get big combat boots
nuts yes I mean you know I mean you
could you could but here's the thing
with keeps is like they have a network
of Expert Medical advisors prescribers
and Care Specialists to support you
making your hair goals a reality and
even though we kid around here folks you
know you got to do it even if you're not
bald it makes sense to just start taking
this
um so you'll never be bald so whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
as you covered remember prevention is
key
treatments taking four to six months to
see results so you have to act fast if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keps.com Tim Dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-p-s.com to get your
first month free
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dylan and and
that's the reality of what we're living
in right yes thank you all reality
reality what else do you think changed
in a big way because of the pandemic
that's never going back there's a lot a
lot of talk about remote work yeah but
now it seems like companies are
realizing that the way to get people to
really work is yeah they got to be in
the office well I also think people's
messages I think people's well I don't
know I think there is still a lot of
hybrid work a lot of remote work going
on uh I think people are saying come in
less than you used to but I also think
people's marriage is like you can't just
sit at home all day like my friend and
his wife work together and like not work
together but worked in a house together
and he goes listen I love her and she
loves me but like it was very healthy
for us to go out every day and have
different social environments right and
then come back together at night right
it's very healthy to have that not like
every minute be in the same house where
she has a corridor I have a corridor and
you know we're meeting all the time you
know right it was healthy so I think I
think that's you know gonna go back
where people realize that there's more
to work than just work there is like
this social Arrangement and I think that
people in a house all the time
that seems to be you know I don't know
how that will be negotiated going
forward but I do think that you're not
going to have all remote work there's no
way
people are going to want to leave their
[ __ ] house you know some people don't
know some people love the idea they
didn't have to commute yes well that's
true too because the commutes are
getting worse and worse because
you know there's more and more people in
cities so the commutes are getting worse
and worse but it was also I think people
just love the idea that they could be
free that they're still working but they
can do it on their terms but then like
jobs started instituting things where
they would monitor your clicks and
monitor your computer they'd give you a
work computer and then people were
installing those programs that moved the
mouse around randomly and clicked on
things nothing is free nothing's free
yeah so whatever you want to get a zoom
camera whatever you get nothing's free
you know it's I think you know after
that period it was interesting because a
lot of people reflected on like what do
I really want to do do I really want to
do what I'm doing right so you saw
Industries
the service industry is still not come
back because people have left the
service industry permanently like a lot
of people left waiting tables people
left
jobs you didn't want to do right and
they were like I want to do something
else and maybe I want to live somewhere
else and I think it gave people a lot of
time to stop and think about the
direction of what they were doing and
then some people changed it you know
it's interesting to see I mean I I still
feel the places still feel understaffed
a little bit some places some places
still feel like they haven't fully come
back well at the end of the pandemic
like when when things were really
opening up again that's what I saw a lot
of places like you would go there and
there was a long wait for tables yeah
and you'd see open tables and they're
like we just don't have enough weights
we don't have people yeah
so it'll be interesting to see what
comes in like I think when we look back
on it I think in like 10 years it's got
to be so far in the in the rear view
that 10 years from now I think people
are going to look at it and be like what
the [ __ ] was that it's going to be
interesting oh for sure right in many
ways in many ways and the fact that
everybody just sort of complied and that
people Everyone of the government by you
know telling other people what to do the
the conflicting information that people
were getting every day do this do that
don't and then knowing now because of
the Twitter files the government was
involved in that oh sure well I mean I
think most people had assumed that I
don't think most people did well a lot
of people did I think I think suspicious
people did most I I know a lot of
suspicious people yeah yeah I mean I
think most people were
kind of like this is a big mess yeah and
the because you know I mean it was a big
mess and I think like a lot of this will
shake out years later it will shake out
years later things tend to shake out
when everyone's like dead yeah things
shake out years later I mean we still
the kind of you know Biden still
wouldn't release some of the Kennedy
files right it's like it's still going
these things still go on people go like
we're holding back a few there's just a
few it's like just released a one page
where you admit you killed them well
you're you're a big on conspiracy
theories you're not well I'm a little
bit sometimes I get back I go back and
forth the this one is a big one the
Kennedy one is a big one and you just
see Tucker Carlson we had that the the
program we said he talked to this guy
who's read the files and the CIA killed
Kennedy yeah that's like they were
involved three-year-olds know that but
the fact that he said it on Fox News is
wild the fact that he said it without
any worry about repercussion yeah I
think everyone knows it's one of those
things now where everybody kind of knows
there was [ __ ] everybody knows there
was really something wrong not everybody
Michael Shermer is convinced Lee Harvey
Oswald actually but that's his beat yeah
shermer's beat is going like this isn't
a conspiracy so the same way you can't
trust a guy whose beat is everything's a
conspiracy right you can't trust someone
who goes nothing's a conspiracy right to
say that there are no conspiracies is
patently but he doesn't do that he says
there are conspiracies understood he's
just reluctant to give in to ones that
he has supported in the past as not
being conspiracies yeah because it's a
huge credibility issue well it's also
like then it causing the question all of
your other assertions yes yeah of course
and I listen I've heard you talk to him
and I've heard him talk and I know that
he's a smart guy and he's done his
research but like he's just come to
conclusions I think that are
unreasonable well the Trinity one the
just the one the Magic Bullet one was
the big one for me what is a guy like
say about Epstein does he just look at
everything and go oh yeah he got sad he
killed him so good question right did we
discuss Epstein with him I don't know I
don't know if we did we've discussed it
so many times I mean it's just like I
feel like you know that with the Kennedy
one the reason that it's they they
haven't let it really seep out and now
it's obviously long enough where it's
seeped out is that it's kind of the
mother of all conspiracies all of them
descend from Kennedy and the meaning
meaning that if you can have a coup in a
country like America where you have an
element of the government or whatever it
is uh Kill the President right and
install the vice president essentially
we don't have a free country we don't
have a democracy all of that [ __ ] is
fake it's all [ __ ] it all sounds
nice but if that is out and widely
believed
you could wave the flag you could have
people go out and sing the national
anthem before the games but if that gets
out people really understand and they
also go where are all those
[ __ ] now what are they doing
now most of them are probably dead well
yeah but until they are they're not what
about the people that are still working
over there like are they have they
gotten more honest in the past 50 years
right everything evolves everything
evolves so they might not be whacking
people out in the open but what are they
doing how are they controlling people
what are you not allowed to ask
questions no that's what the Kennedy one
for me has always been like that's the
mother of all of them they can't let
that one
slip and when it slips however it'll be
some like Rogue it was a rogue element
of the guy and we don't you know we have
no idea and
but that's when they came up with the
term conspiracy theory that's right
conspiracy theorists that's right and
they they use it as disparaging term
yeah that's what the origin of it that
was planted I mean if people looked at
our system of government they would not
come to the same conclusions that we are
taught it is in school we are taught it
as a representative democracy a republic
right you know we're obviously it's not
a direct democracy it's representative
you elect people they go in they debate
and if you did a study of our system of
government by the way like Princeton
University did a while ago and they
concluded it was an oligarchy I mean
they just did an independence study and
looked at what was going on you would of
course go oh this isn't the full story
you know and and I think stuff like
Kennedy uh really exposes all of that
that you know there are people that
operate in the shadows and they get they
get what they want a lot of them get
what they want
and the fact that the Epstein thing is
just sort of done it was hilarious I
mean you got Andrew Tate by the way
Andrew Tate they're acting like Andrew
Tate
and I'm not saying you know but think of
the political ramification of the
Epstein story what's a bigger story
Andrew Tate human trafficking in Romania
I'm sorry Romania but that's Tuesday
and you can get hookers in the cabs in
Romania it's just it is what it is like
the cab driver will say to you would you
like I mean it's true that's all a fact
now Andrew Tate I don't know what he was
doing he nothing's been proven but he's
been charged with this
but the abstain thing was all proven you
have genuine victims coming forward
saying these things
nobody's been arrested in conjunction
with it and against the fact that he was
whacked and the cameras were off and
those [ __ ] people that were the
security guards that day yeah they have
to be [ __ ] their pants
well they probably got taken care of you
think so U.S Virgin Islands district
attorney fired days after suing JP
Morgan Chase over Jeffrey Epstein ties
by the way do you know that Biden flew
to the Virgin Islands for vacation and
then the woman was fired shortly after
inference surprised woman Right In
fairness to Biden he did not know where
he was flying he had you know like well
people that were with him did yeah I
mean interesting I wonder why he would
go there but it's nice it's pretty there
it's beautiful though yeah it's pretty
pretty Biden's not I mean he's just so
old he doesn't know they just put him in
how much do you think he's aware and how
much do you think he just falls apart on
camera I think he's aware to a degree of
what's going on I just think he was
select I mean again Bernie was
sandbagged they were like we're not
gonna have him in right so who's the guy
and it's like Biden's been the guy
Biden's the guy that you know they just
want somebody they know right what do
you think happens in 2024 DeSantis
and he'll be fine he'll be I think he
wins yeah and he'll just Trump
yeah really yeah I think now Trump's the
weakest he's ever been really yeah
politically Trump's very good he's very
good in the primaries though so I mean
that would be interesting to watch but I
just I just feel like people are it's
not gonna have the same effect when a
comic goes out and you see it for the
first time it's amazing if it's the same
stuff the Third special you go okay like
right I think it is he's it's wearing
thin uh his appeal I think DeSantis is
who the party wants well the Santa's is
going to get the reasonable Republicans
he'll get the reasonable Republican he's
not going to get the Qing on people
though yeah but he won't get down but
they're not a huge Force and uh I met
one I met one in Aspen yeah
this lady came up she sounds fine she
grabbed me in the line and she was with
her daughter she says I love you this
older lady yeah she goes I love you you
are out there speaking the truth she's
saying all those things are going oh
thank you thank you I'm trying to be
nice and then she goes and Donald Trump
is our real president yeah I go he's
definitely not I go you can Google that
she's like oh my God they got to you
that's right oh they got it to me yeah
it was really funny because her
daughters were like her daughters were
super reasonable yes and they were
younger and they're like oh mom's kind
of crazy it's like the Shane Gillis joke
which is a great joke he's like you want
a fox and his dad you don't want an MSN
but if you have a Fox News Mom it's a
bad mom you know like it's a cute you
know it's the same it's a great job and
it's the same thing that I say a lot
about like it's just the Boomers have
gotten to a point now where they are
this is politics has become a sport
for Boomers where they are it's MSNBC or
Fox News it's right or left right and a
lot of them are sitting there and
they're sitting in their chair and
they've got a heating blanket on they've
got pills everywhere they're drinking
wine their brain has been melted and
they're just trying to they've got a few
years left not all of them some of them
will live but you know they're at the
end a lot of them and they're in their
70s or wherever they are some you know
my parents age their 70s and they're
basically like
you know trying to have a little fun on
the way out and that's what I look at Q
Anon as it's actually just fun we should
stop saying it's a threat we should stop
treating it like it's a thing it's just
fun people want to have fun and it is
fun to believe that Donald Trump's still
the president and he's going to lead a
secret army of whatever Christian people
through tunnels to kill everybody out
like it's just fun they just want to
have some fun that's really what it is I
think that's what I saw from the Q Anon
documentary yeah they're just having fun
to the storm it's like they were just
obsessed with the idea that they were a
part of something they just want to be
unaware of and this is like they just
want to go around there's nothing to do
anymore there's like a religion in a lot
of ways it gave their life meaning yeah
because there's not much to do you know
there was this great book called bowling
Alone written about like how American
social institutions have fallen apart
things like the Knights of Columbus or
whatever like social clubs or people
used to be a part of small communities
where like people would be vested
involved in their Community they you
know do that anymore so the social
Fabric's been torn apart and people need
to be a part of something
so what if it's the Q Anon give them the
fake Capital to storm you know like they
just want to be a part of something it's
just what they want to be a part of and
that's a problem with the charismatic
leader like Trump that's comes along and
he tells them you're a part of this and
we're together until they start storming
the capital but it's cute if you watch a
killing on rally it's kind of cute it's
fun it's folksy it's a Civil War
reenactment they're all nuts they're all
bored what's Wild is how many people
were infiltrated yes how many of those
groups were infiltrated by the FBI yeah
yeah because they're bored well that's
the Whitmer case yeah the FBI wants to
come in and how many of her uh 12 out of
14. We're fbias the two guys that
weren't are doing big time yeah they're
doing longs long stretches well this is
one of them was talking about it and one
of the things that he was talking about
was like I never planned on doing
anything they coerced me into all of
this I've planned everything and you
know this is
the Boston Bomber Boston bombers it was
weird too there's something weird about
that the FBI goes yeah we don't know who
they are and then Russian intelligence
goes we told you who they were
Samantha Fuller whose father Graham
Fuller was a huge CIA guy who's
architect of their middies policy she
married this guy ruthless
his nephews are the guys who did the
bombing that's odd that a CIA family
this woman married Bruce Lee's and IV
his nephews who are traveling back and
forth to Dagestan
and the FBI had no idea who they were
Chuck Grassley who's a senator writes a
letter to the FBI going why were you
doing surveillance the night that Sean
Collier the MIT police officer was
killed in the neighborhood of the
tsarnaevs did you know about them did
you had you had any relationship with
them it's odd and then the FBI wrote
back we were in that we were in and
around MIT because that was the MIT
police officer was killed the day after
or the night of the the bombing where
they supposedly killed you know the
police officer and then were trying to
get away
um and they robbed the 7-Eleven they did
all this stuff truck rests he's like why
are you guys in that area and they were
like we were around MIT uh for on uh for
a separate reason the FBI was there for
a separate reason this is also a thing
where they killed one of their friends
like one of their they had a routine
interview at the guy's house they didn't
make him come to an FBI office and one
of their friends uh this guy ended up
dead four FBI agents in the room
interviewing this guy supposedly he went
to go grab something and kill them and
then he ended up shot dead so really
yeah the FBI eyes like they're it's
weird
the FBI the entrapment and the stuff
they get into is weird it's odd the
entrapment thing is strange it's strange
talked before about the story about the
19 year old guy I think it was in Dallas
who they talked him into uh using a bomb
and activating this bomb you know it's
like uh yeah some fundamentalism right
they talked him into doing this but it
was a fake bomb right they gave him and
then when he went to activate this fake
bomb then they swooped in and took him
yeah like they gave him the bomb they
told them to do it they yeah then he was
young and gullible and
it's crazy what they do this is kind of
what they do
this is just the way they operate and
they don't want the way they operate to
become public
so all these things that happen but you
got to think that also by doing that you
can infiltrate legitimately dangerous
organizations and you can stop
legitimately dangerous things I think
that's some of what they do that's
probably the orange sure the origins of
it some of it is I think good I think
the problem you run into with that is
it's so murky yeah and it's such a fine
line when you're dealing with mentally
unhealthy people and when you compromise
somebody or you're you recruit somebody
as an informant it's Weighing on them
they're crazy they don't know what's
going on they're anxious they're like
you know I think they promise this guy
supposedly they might have uh this guy
Tamron or whatever like might have been
promised citizenship or they might they
hang they dangle carrots with people
they will make you say well do this
we'll do that we'll give you money we'll
do this what's the big conspiracy theory
about the Boston bombings the FBI again
these are just guys that they were you
know probably trying to set up and then
the [ __ ] bomb went off meaning that
again it was just a similar thing where
it's like the FBI had either recruited
them or in the process of trying to
recruit them and then you know if you if
you come clean with that the American
public goes what the [ __ ] are you doing
right but what yeah the conspiracy
theory is it that the FBI is covering up
that they had prior relationships with
this or knives that they knew them that
there was any pre-existing relationship
with them at all but there's not that
they instigated this
well what is instigated right that's a
big question right and you know did they
did they
give them the bomb we don't know right
but they I don't you know but there are
instances where they do give people
stuff right or they do allow people to
purchase weapons or they do you know
like did they instigate the Wimmer
kidnapping supposedly they probably did
they're putting this idea the fact that
there's 12. there's 12 guys out of 14
guys so when you when you talk about the
jedias it is just weird that
you know number one there's not a lot
known about the trial that they put
special administrative measures on the
trial uh which means that like nobody
can really speak out about what happened
it's all very tightly controlled and
they said it's National Security but
then you're like but you told us they
weren't related to any terrorist yeah
thing so why if they're not related to
any overseas terrorist cell and they act
alone what the hell is National Security
so again you're just supposed to go like
hey got him
they got them they got them
horribly like that's people like my Aunt
they just go they go stop with that go
to Markle now markle's been a racist to
Meghan Markle it's like it's just an
endless circus of nonsense you're never
supposed to get in the weeds with
anything and if you do you're meant to
look insane
because some of the people in the weeds
are insane some of the people that will
will have the conversation I'm having
right now are crazy most most so that
becomes a problem your allies become
people who are [ __ ] nuts and they're
like Chrissy Teigen has a tunnel under
there and you go okay she does it she
does she's selling [ __ ] cookware
um so you you know you start looking
into things dude when you start looking
into serial killers
it's crazy like when you start looking
at Son of Sam and David and this idea
that there might have been more people
doing that [ __ ] like there's been books
written about the fact that David
Berkowitz like maybe didn't do all of
those murders but he was the guy that
went down did you send me the article
about they never caught the guy who
built the bomb
I send you yes I send you a lot of that
stuff but didn't you send me it like yes
I said in an article today where it was
a guy from the Boston Marathon bombing
where that you know he had gotten into
multiplication with his parents and they
they can't ran in his house and I don't
know Ipswich which is the clam town or
you know all these places
um and they found like a pressure cooker
bomb and it was like the type of bomb
that would have been using the marathon
and they also proved that he knew Tamil
like they had a you know connection so
it was like oh they were like is this
the guy that built the bomb so who knows
Michelle McPhee who's a journalist in
Boston wrote the book I think it was
called maximum harm about the Boston
Marathon she did a lot of great work on
it and she wrote a book basically kind
of ripping the official story of Park
going like the feds are clearly covering
up something here
and you know it's interesting and she's
a fun uh journalist I think she punched
a cop or something she's got a dealie
and punched a cop that's something good
Boston good you know something good I
trust people I trust you if you've done
something like that really yeah if
you've gotten drunk and like punched a
cop it's like oh okay
I get it
you know what I mean it's like I I try I
have more I'm more inclined to
to trust you in that scenario you know
but that's the thing it's like you just
gotta enjoy life because it is you know
you're never gonna you're never gonna
figure it out
you're never gonna figure it out you'll
never figure it out you'll never know
nobody's gonna you'll never know what
really went down
no you know and that's part of the
purpose that's part of the purpose
because there's so much noise and
there's so much craziness and people get
mad at me and they're like no you you're
cynical and you tell people not to care
it's like I'm not telling people not to
care I'm just telling people like just a
lot a certain amount of time to caring
it's a good diet don't consume too much
most people aren't good at that though
it's a good thing with diets chewing on
here's the thing with diet it's like
you're supposed to take in a little bit
of conspiracy every now and then Q
anon's Denny's
Q anon's just banana salted caramel
pancake like food doesn't even make
sense yeah Q Anon is everyday fast food
I tried the gate before we go I I wanted
I wanted to get you a Comanche gift for
Christmas and it's very difficult
but just the idea that I wanted to do it
I think you should register is really
nice I appreciate it I called the
Comanche Museum in Oklahoma and they had
like we they're like we have like towels
and shirts I'm like no that's not what I
want I wanted like an artifact and you
cannot buy them no they don't want you
to have them I know that like if you dig
up uh Arrowhead they'll kill me they
believe that it belongs to whatever
Nation other thing I was reading about
do I want to curse myself to give you
something but so I I wanted to get a
Comanche thing that's why I texted you
I'm like where are they coming at you I
want to text you about the manual yeah
it was it's impossible to get anything
so
thanks anyway but I really wanted to
thanks for the thought it was a great
thought and it would have been great if
it happened have you ever read into them
I want to read more about you said they
were like a nomadic and it was the wild
yeah it's right here Empire of the
summer moon is probably the best book on
it interesting it's really good are they
your favorites well they're the most
fascinating to me because uh they were
the reason why people couldn't get
across the Plains and and into the
Warriors they were the yeah well they
they would set people up by giving them
homesteads like hey yeah you would you
like all these acres in Oklahoma go
there yeah and they'd go there they'd
get slaughtered and then that would be a
reason why they would bring in the Army
and then were they the toughest time
well what they were were the tribe that
mastered uh horse like horse racing so
they they were Horsemen they knew how to
ride horses they knew how to raise
horses they had an abundance of horses
and they would ride on them and shoot
arrows while they were riding they they
mastered equestrianism amazing yeah so
they would like hang on to the horse
sideways and shoot from under the
horse's neck as they were riding so they
were riding and shoot arrows while they
were protected by the body of the horse
do you are you do you think the Avatar
stopped there's any obviously Native
Americans are kind of pissed about it
but not all well I just sent you that
article which is but that's just
everything right no matter what the
[ __ ] movie is if it's Maverick Tom
Cruise's movie or right there's always
going to be someone that's upset about
it yeah this is an outrage culture
outrage is
I think it portrays advertises if it's
based on the Native American it portrays
them as like like really good people oh
they're the most noble I mean they're
the most people in Avatar are the the
navi or the most noble they're the most
noble you know what's interesting that
someone pointed out all the in every
movie you have diversity but in Avatar
all the humans are white because all the
humans are evil yeah I think the Nazi
are interesting people you know what I'm
saying yeah of course the navi are the
most noble but I think they're also
short-sighted because I think the sky
people are giving them really good
opportunities and Pathways to money and
profit and I think the navi are like hey
we're just going to be in the forest
forever it's like you're not let's get
real like they're ignoring tourism
they're ignoring a lot of things I
believe in progress
I believe in print no I literally do and
I don't think you can just like oh I'm
blue and
I think eventually it's like enough and
the people they when in 2009 when people
went to see Avatar they got Avatar
depression because the way those people
lived was it so resonated with them like
the way they want to be they want to be
they think go to Brazil go to Brazil and
get bit by a bug the size of a bird it's
all [ __ ] nature [ __ ] and the planets are
done no the reality of the planets are
dumb the only thing good really is
casinos and like inside things that's
why people like Dubai they build
everything inside yeah it's like this
nature [ __ ] it's people like fetishize
it go out in it for a day you're shot
you have skin cancer it's over do you
have anything to promote I mean how
hilarious is this to ask you do you have
anything do you want to tell do you have
anything to promote no I don't I don't
promote anything I don't even I've never
even promoted my show history I doubt
it's done well
um uh yeah Tim dilloncomedy.com if you
want to get live tickets to the shows
how's touring been it's been fun I mean
we're we're doing doing uh we're in
clubs now to build material yeah and
then we'll probably start some theaters
in the fall where like you're a
different person well I have multiple
personalities no it's me but I just I
was talking the Royal way it seems yeah
you know what I mean yes
um but yeah it's been fun we did Irvine
Improv on New Year's they were fun they
were it was great do you like doing New
Years
you know every year I go I'm not gonna
do it and every year I do it that's what
I do I just like to work because like
everywhere I don't want to do it but
then like I I you know you get an offer
and they go they want you to do and I'm
like I could entertain people over New
Year's Eve um and you know somebody said
to me once they said
whether it's New Year's Eve or New
Year's Day do something you want to do
for the year
it was interesting they were like do
something that whether if you're if
you're jogging if you're this if you're
that do something start the year the way
you want to finish the year so I love
doing stand up so I start and maybe you
start the year doing it
you know the way I don't know but why
don't you work
um it just seems like too much of an
amateur hour like it is you know it's
just everybody just wants a cheer when's
the countdown yeah see how many people
are angry at Don Lemon because he missed
the countdown have you ever done this
you've probably never done it oh I've
done it multiple times yeah yeah many
many times I've done I used to do New
Year shows every year so now you just
take it off do you spend it with your
family yeah soft it was fun it's a
little soft I enjoyed it you're not
worried about money no I'm kidding
I don't think that it's the same kind of
show I think it's a fun show yeah and I
think that people like their noisemakers
they like those little horns that they
get to blow we brought a woman on stage
at the end to just help us do the
countdown well the thing about La is we
did a countdown at 8 30. it was totally
fake there were two shows the early Kent
I'm like this doesn't even correspond
with New York it's a completely fake
countdown and everyone's in the mall
it's just why did you do a countdown
because they make you
yeah so that was in the contract you
have to do the count it's part of the
thing you have to say I'm not doing a
countdown
I used to do early shows
a fake countdown I think the audience
kind of enjoyed the countdown I don't
think so I mean you know they like it
they love it they like making noise on
cue yeah it's they're like yeah it's new
it's a fun you know it's a fun thing to
do and next year I'm like this year I
went I'm not doing it next year I
guarantee I'll do it next year people
love being sort of like corralled like
that like yeah yeah ready go yeah we're
gonna do the same talk show taping oh
God yeah well just kind of the same
thing like all right everybody applaud
yeah let's go Applause signs are wild no
it's crazy that whole thing is wild it's
such orchestrated enjoyment of a show
that's right like when you see the
person who's the producer waving at the
crowd doing it you go to one of these
things people don't know there's signs
that flash that say Applause right which
is [ __ ] crazy and then there's a
person who's like doing this to the
crowd getting out of jail excited so
when you see everybody cheering along
it's not organic because people don't
know who half the people are anymore
like when you go to see a taping a
Fallon you have no idea who these people
are somebody comes out and it's like
give it up and you're like okay they're
like you know do they have a say at all
and who goes on those shows you think
the audience is yeah like Seth Meyers
does he have a say uh interesting I
don't know that's a whole area of Comedy
I know very little about like I don't
know how the guest selection process
could you imagine though doing your show
if somebody chose your guests yeah that
to me sounds like hell it would be crazy
well it sounds like a totally different
thing it's not not that you wouldn't get
great guests you probably get a lot of
really interesting conversations but not
being able like one of the beautiful
things about podcasts you get to pick
who you're talking to yeah well it's
like they wanted me for hot ones one
once and then they go we got someone
else and I was like oh
like because I was like very down the
list like everyone else had canceled
they couldn't get me one and then they
go well you do hot ones I go yeah and
then they go we got someone else and I'm
like what was this how long ago was this
probably like I don't know like a year
ago or something but it was just one of
those things where you realize like
you're like okay I got it because you'll
get it you know they get somebody for
what you doing now probably you don't
feel upset that they canceled on you I
was a little it was a little [ __ ] up
but I'll still do it I'll still do it if
it moves some tickets if it gets people
to come see me or whatever they probably
will you have a great hot one yeah so it
was weird to me that they would just dip
out they might have Googled me too and
they're like wait what like what are we
nuts like and I get it they want like
you know listen I'm you know I just did
an acting thing and I kind of did good
um in it I had three lines and during it
the director said to me because I'm kind
of at my wit's end with you I don't know
why you're doing the wrong thing I was
moving a book I had to pass someone a
book and the thing with acting is
everything has to be the same time
different like everything's got to be
the same every time right and I wasn't
doing it the same way he's like you're
doing you're passing the book like
differently I think I don't know what's
wrong with you and I'm like oh I'm sorry
because I would get nervous right so
because you're putting the pen on the
book differently he's like sometimes
your hand is over the book he goes
sometimes you take two fingers and push
it like that he goes what is he you know
what's wrong with you so but I think by
the end we did about 17 takes and by the
end
um I think it was good at the end to
decide to never act again well by the
end he was like you did a really good
job and I was like thank you so much and
I have to believe him I haven't been
back to set since yeah now no but I
think I did good it's fine or you know I
think I did well okay it's acting stuff
I think I did great I think I did great
and but he was very he seemed upset I
can't wait to watch it now yeah because
that's all I'm gonna think about edit it
out but I think I did really well and I
think during it he just the director
seemed very upset and the other actor
seemed a little mad but they were nice
that's good they were really nice but so
I don't know we'll see we'll see
CAA was like that might open up some
more doors I go well I don't know
open up some more doors do you want to
do that though would you want to be on a
set for 16 hours a day for five months
no but five months is no but if they
said like two weeks
yeah and I come in and I just get to be
funny I don't I shouldn't carry this
unless like it's all about me and I'm
involved in the create you know but like
if they bring me into a thing where they
go you can kind of be like you and be
funny but that wasn't this this was like
a different but like if I was like yeah
but you know
yeah I wouldn't want to do it for five
months but like you know a couple of
months like if you know it would depend
on you know if it was something where I
felt
like I feel good at podcasting I feel
good at stand up because I really worked
at those things I feel like I could be
funny but you know it would have to be a
real specific thing well the acting
thing is it's very specific in that you
know you're brought in for a very
very specific goal but you're supposed
to move this aspect of the plot you're
supposed to be this guy that does this
thing I think some people enjoy that
kind of work where you can kind of like
lock into this character and then you
see how it affects the script and see
how it affects the movie and you get
excited about it yeah I mean and I I I I
I I could be excited about that I feel
like
um you're too free though the problem is
like the directors are less excited
about you you've gotten to this point
where you can be so free and then you've
developed an audience that's the problem
is free and then that's the problem yeah
well I don't think the good news is I
don't think anyone's really
go like I'm not going to be a marquee
actor like if I ever did a movie I'd
want it to be a cult classic on woke but
look at that very funny Bert Chrysler
the machine he's just like yeah he
released the trailer on the podcast that
I did yeah and but that's him after he
released that I could do because that's
like his story yeah that's what I'm
talking about you as a corrupt mortgage
guy yeah something like that something
like that yeah that you could do that I
could do like you could do your story
that I could do yeah yeah I mean selling
subprime mortgages it would have to be
that it couldn't be I'm not going to
come into like a roll but it would have
to be like far enough from 2008 where
people aren't mad at you anymore
right well I think yeah I mean I think I
think I've done a great job
rehabilitating the image of subprime
mortgage sales people
that's one of the things I believe I've
done I I think I've kind of because the
the borrowers were criminals too through
also but did they know there were
criminals or were they were just like
given an opportunity everybody wants
money if you look at the word victim
throughout history you've done a big
history guy a a imagine explaining to
someone in history you were a victim and
then they're going what were you a
victim of they go somebody gave me 700
Grand you go what
you were I was a horrible victim in this
predatory scam what was the scam
somebody gave me 700 Grand I didn't have
a job
you were a victim no everybody played
the game and then you know it's musical
chairs the chairs went out I lost the
house my house is foreclosed on I bought
a house when I was 22. I had no money
but a 600 000 House in Long Island did
you really it sold five years later for
250 000 without a good investment
I would never sell someone something I
wouldn't sell myself
I was a cocaine addict and I wanted a
house
[Laughter]
I love houses
I hate I don't like homes homes are
weird what do you mean people that have
families and like love in the home I
prefer just a nice house to destroy
really yeah I'm gonna have a I have an
investment course called many houses no
homes
how to own and abuse real estate yeah no
I mean yeah and then I lost the house
too and I bounced back I moved into some
dump and I did stand up for three years
you're funny and the best years of my
life were spent doing stand-up you know
and eating pizza in New York and then
you know and then I get I I came and I
did your show and things were okay so
it's gonna be fine
thank you very much thank you I
appreciate it I appreciate you thank you
thanks thanks for having me of course